I have a question for all of you what
happens to the punk bands when they find
themselves in complete alignment with
the billion-dollar multinational
corporations you actually ask me I'm
asking you I'm asking but I thought you
were I thought oh no no no literally
what happens I don't know I mean I know
the funny answers that people give in so
well band names I'll just give it to you
I think this the the winner the winner
of the funny band names is Rage on
behalf of the Machine and this is from
based in PA comedy gold says free
sheeple well done I agree we listen take
rage against the machines lyrics yeah
play them today they're quite literally
the machine they are just rage it is it
is rage on behalf of the Machine think
about it yeah the riots for black lives
matter the government supports it
they're painting in the streets yeah
every major corporation is plastering
the message everywhere so when you go
out and rage on behalf
you are the machine yep you're a giant
rage-filled hate machine yeah that's
true so this is act I actually thought
of this because I saw for those of you
familiar with Paramore hayley williams
who is like the front woman of the band
put up a poster that was called say
their names i I could be getting it
wrong cuz I just saw this passively and
I'm not gonna pretend like Paramore is
the epitome of real punk rock their pop
punk in the 2000s but it still made me
think of this because there are other
punk bands that are in long with the
establishment we'll get to this but I
saw that I looked up what what had
happened so she had posted this poster
of a I guess it was a bunch of names of
people who like you know unarmed black
people or people have been killed by
police and she got attacked for it okay
I say attacked but she got a bunch of
angry messages saying it's offensive and
you're profiting off their names or
whatever so she tweeted she was taking
the poster down and I thought to myself
you know I'm again not trying to pretend
that Paramore is like the epitome of
punk rock certainly not you know it's
like you know I would never email pop
equate them to punk
no but it was supposed to be like youth
it was youthful exuberant rock you know
what I mean it was like teenage angst so
it sure it was it was like the point I'm
making is I saw that I thought about it
like if you're supposed to be a rebel
challenging the system but here you are
saying so sorry everybody you know I
understand this is a big mainstream high
profile cause that everyone loves and
supports and the government supports it
so a better example would be bad
religion which we talked about before
yeah writing their attempt at an anti
alt-right song which is actually I guess
inadvertently Pro alt-right but
regardless of whether or not you have
all these modern innovations of you know
of punk bands or anti-establishment
music and art what happens now to even
the historic music Rage Against the
Machine from the 90s or two that you
know as was the 90s I guess yeah now
it's quite literally like
congratulations you've lived long enough
to see her because your self become the
machine actually a villain actually had
a question about this even in high
school and you and I have talked about
this a little bit because in 2002 I
think it was bad religion came out with
Kyoto now which was their song in favor
of the Kyoto Protocol which is very I
know if you're an environmentalist and
you also apparently really like big
government like I couldn't figure out I
was like are you Against the Machine are
you with the Machine because that looks
a lot like the machine to me and I was a
conservative and then I was like if you
were really gonna be Punk maybe you want
to be conservative because they actually
don't like the government I never made
sense to me
so I don't know maybe this is just the
well attenuation of that it's it's like
they were they were advocating for a
bigger machine yeah
the machine is it big enough to the
machine is it big enough threat some
punk songs and just totally lean into
you know we are the Machine everything
we say is pro-establishment
and that crazy yeah doesn't how man and
so this is something I don't know who
coined this was it Paul Joseph Watson
Kurt conservatism is a new county
culture mm-hmm I know that it kind of is
but this is a different kind of
conservatism the idea was that like I
guess what he is saying is that if you
go back in time the idea of wearing a
suit and going to church is like a
counterculture because the establishment
is like super far left
yeah but what we're doing is still
anti-establishment and we are not suit
wearing stodgy really was this show
right now oh for sure
oh god like we are still skateboarding
musicians you're a vegan like this is
what a lot of punk rock was back in the
day at least in certain respects not
completely or entirely you know I mean
you could overlap with it but
skateboarding you know yeah
skateboarding playing music and
challenging the establishment and
calling for freedom and liberty it's
it's not a maybe they subvert ADIZ
cultures on purpose it's interesting men
remember what I was saying with the
conspiracy where Trump is a part of the
deep state yeah the idea was that they
that Trump is really part of the global
elite billionaires and he is playing a
you know he's he's playing this role of
the outsider challenging the deep state
so that it can bring people back into
the machine but this is the second layer
to that the overall conspiracy and I'm
not saying it's true at all I'm just
saying it's something people say Trump
is friends with the Clintons who runs a
tiller it's all an act he wants you to
think that he's stealing the country
back from the corporate evil and so what
happened now as you get people like Alex
Jones who used to be very
anti-establishment straight up
supporting Trump and you get punk rock
bands that were straight-up
anti-establishment now completely in
support of the establishment political
positions sure whatever has happened
it's completely made everyone in favor
of one form of the establishment hmm
yeah one of the other one of the other
so that was that it was like now you've
got you've got people who used to be
very anti-government libertarian being
like in support of the federal
government calling for them to take
action bring out law and order you know
these were the more small government
right link right leaning people now
saying we need law and order we need
Trump to come in and enforce the law and
then you get the punk rock bands Rage
Against the Machine now literally
putting on rock concerts sanctioned by
the government where they paint their
political messages in the street you
know legally with protection from the
police you actually have the cops this
is the best part seeing these videos of
these young kids dancing with cops yeah
there was one eye camera but it was but
was like a street and the cop
was doing some shuffle dance with
everybody and they're all laughing and
cheering and I'm like it's so weird to
see young people not rebelling what what
happened there with with why don't kids
rebel anymore this is strange only
ignorant sleepless you think they're
just ignorant oh yeah but that's all it
is because they've always been exactly
right
I mean everyone is ignorant until they
you know like on any subject they're not
like preview to and then you climb out
of that ignorance when you research
whatever subject it is so I'm ignorant
of many political things still you know
I'm slowly you know learning my place
and understanding the whole realm of and
you know you just see that there's more
and more the problem is everyone thinks
that they know everything so a lot of
these people these young young people
think that they know everything they
don't realize that they are ignorant
they think that they've just I mean
everyone you know think back when you're
20 it's like you were I know everything
like I'm finally out of the house like
my parents were wrong I finally can you
know it used to be rebelling right but
now it's more like keep deforming well
because they have the Internet and
they're all they all cluster together
because they find each other easy you
know or they go into college yeah and
then they're finding each other they're
they're clumping together and then the
ignorance Fester's and they don't they
don't climb out of the ignorance they
stay in it you know they don't have to
just it's not so much in my opinion
about rebelling against parents which is
how we view it I think it's about
asserting your individuality that's
what's gone yeah when I was a kid I was
like I do what I want a you know you
can't tell me what to do shut up I do
what I want
yeah and that was rebelling asserting
like here is Who I am and there it was
important in my opinion when it comes to
cultural and literal evolution yeah
because it allows life to to challenge
and find better ways of solving problems
if you have a bunch of people trying a
bunch of different things 19 you know
out of a hundred ninety-nine fail but
one person improves then that
improvement can trickle to the masses
and then lift everybody up yeah so that
asserting your individuality was a
benefit to our society in our culture
and now it's gone now you have these
young kids totally in favor you know you
know there's their pro-establishment
yeah they're not the the individuality
is gone check out check out this this is
this is really amazing this picture
someone tweeted this
it is a punk looking young woman if you
think your gun or alternative but you
don't support the BLM movement you're a
poser
interesting she has an anarchy a on her
Jean vest she's also wearing a shirt
this is a cab which I'll give you the
family-friendly version all cops are bad
but the Enter key thing I find
interesting because the government of
New York just painted black lives matter
on the street so you your movement is in
favor of the establishment government
that's or any political party just not
cops apparently why are you wearing the
anarchy symbol
oh no they're defunding the police right
yeah yeah baby yeah they like the
government bill de blasio right yeah so
the Anarchy makes no sense right ACAB
really really pisses me off
because it's it's just them going you
know all people are racist is basically
what that mess also what they could say
I know all people are racist and it's
like no you're ignorant is is spilling
out and splashing all over me I have to
go shower it's you can't stand it yeah I
know people that are cops and they're
awesome they're awesome people they okay
it's so this is what what I see every
every layer of our cultural institutions
which come well before politics are
under the control of intersectional ists
mm-hmm
they have they they are establishment
conformists you know they have weird
views they're racists look you know I
often we joke about like it's a meme
when I say on mixed-race and stuff which
but but I think people really really
didn't understand like I've had
conversations with other people who are
like Papa meaning like half asian or
whatever and co-op a quarter Asian and
there are serious concerns about what a
leftist identitarian future means I was
talking to Sargon
because he was reading white fragility
and what he basically said was she she
basically poo-poos mixed-race people
like if they're not a part of this
worldview you
so you're not a part of it well what it
means is basically I'll put it this way
my general understanding of other
countries is that if I were to live in
places where my family is from okay
I would have been a second-class citizen
not in America though in America we've
bypassed like we've succeeded we've
we've passed these laws we have these
rulings right we're all Americans yep
period so when I grew up what ideal what
I had to deal with that my family was
people who thought Aryan racists so we
had like someone threw a brick through
our family vehicle window we had our
house was vandalized and I was a little
kid and so it was like I don't
understand you know people are attacking
us I guess it was like very obvious and
you look at our family that it was not
you know your typical white American
family so when I was growing up I was
like wow man look at this neighborhood
we won like we're it's a Star Trek
future man I remember when I was a
little kid watching Star Trek with my
dad and I'm like this is the future man
it's going to be people of all different
types and creeds and colors just living
together peacefully yeah that's what it
felt like my high school I went I went
to high school out here outside
Philadelphia and there was all sorts of
colors and pretty much every single
person I ever interacted in high school
was cool you know sure there was some
bullies but it's like and that's that's
not a race race issue that's a
authoritarian you know it's bullies
there's no bullies exist trolls on the
internet it's like they don't even know
what the color your skin is they're
bullies that's that's it's what trolls
do that's what they want my troll my
concern is like we saw the whiteness
training in Seattle right you brought up
earlier in Seattle they had all the
white people would do like an undoing
whiteness thing oh it's crazy they don't
know how to deal with mixed-race people
and I was having a conversation with a
friend of mine and I told I was telling
her why I thought this was bad and I
said I want you to imagine for a second
what it must feel like to not have the
luxury of of living the community where
everyone is the same race right because
it's something she brought to me she was
like minorities have a thing about race
all the time and why people don't which
is not true
but there are communities that is true
ok so now I want you to imagine
something imagine you're a minority okay
and you wake up one day to see that many
people you know who are white are now
calling for white collective action and
they're calling for the formation of
white racial identity groups do you
think that would make them more or less
comfortable less yes so I was like I
don't like the idea that my friends are
now going like this ok everyone listen
up Tim you go over there we're not
talking to you here's what we're gonna
do and I'm like I don't care if you
think you're the good guy or not that is
not fun yeah it's not feel good at all
right and then you tell me what I was
told was that I have to choose to
identify as white then and I was like
that's that's complete BS right the
future they're building will do weird
things to me and my family
and it also has very profound
implications on what on who I choose
have a family with you know do I want to
put someone through the the the ethnic
ambiguity or racial ambiguity problem
these people are awful yeah they are
they're trying to inject racism back
into society there they won't let it go
away they don't want to because it's one
of their control pieces I went to Seoul
South Korea and I met some I have some
friends who are 100% Korean born in
America and who have been there and I
met some people who are what happens in
Korean born in Korea and boy was an
interesting conversation as young people
they were very nice to me
yeah but they explained to me that in
Southeast Asia
I would not be for the most part
acceptable I'd probably get by just fine
but outcome I would come across many
roadblocks based on racism that I would
never experience in America and you look
at somebody brought this up in the chat
yeah I think the other day that in Japan
you can't even open a bank account
unless you are like from Japan and you
are Japanese because a lot it's like
dude America's laws are rare yeah so
many countries have overt racial
identity in their laws for your kind no
this is what I was saying the other day
about how how can we how can they deny
that we are that America is not on the
forefront of showing what it's like to
be free to be a civil to show what
equality is there there
actually trying to disassemble that and
that we have that we've we put it in
place in in the 60s Martin Luther King
got killed for it and he and and man I
was listened to a man named Shelby
Steele incredible man you you should you
could check him out on the Hoover
Institute they have a lot of amazing
interviews on YouTube and he was talking
about it and they he was like I would
not take reparations because I I've
earned my keep here I worked hard to get
to where I am I saw I was alive during
in the 60s when we were actually
fighting for civil rights we had a
message we knew exactly what we needed
to do and now these people everyone's
confused people are confused because
they don't actually know what is the
plan you know they don't have a clear
message it just you ask anyone you can
just move along the list of different
people and ask them what do you think
the plan is you know okay the original
originally it was police reform right
right well they we tried police reform
there was a legitimate bill on the table
and now people are saying well that
wasn't enough and it's like you didn't
read the bill did you I still haven't
heard back from those you know those
those ragers on Facebook that ever be
that I was like here's the bill read it
talk to me zero zip nothing they don't
care they don't want that
it's not about police reform what is it
about no one even know I'll tell you
this it's not about accommodating
marginalized people either that
absolutely absolutely cry out so this
was the culmination of the conversation
with my friend when they were basically
saying you know why people have the
luxury of never experiencing race and
then when I said imagine waking up where
you come from a mixed race family you've
dealt with issues of racism and you see
all of these white people now forming a
white racial identity group right like I
I don't do people on sit there go like
hey that's a good thing I remember that
that was great you know they're going
like oh I thought we were so I asked her
you know I basically said when you
proposed segregation based on race you
have to understand that it was you your
ideology and progressives
in 1967 that got a
which created mixed-race relationships
in this country Loving v Virginia 1967
made it so that it was legally protected
they couldn't discriminate people of
different races could have mixed-race
children you have now created a couple
Eve two or three generations now of
mixed-race families you know and with
your identitarian ISM and segregation
you are basically telling them fu and
you want to go back in time what is that
it that that's like you're basically
just chopping off a group of people that
your side you know fought for yeah right
actually the progressives mmm-hmm
there's no answer I mean that's that's
that's probably the better argument like
why would you want to go so so the
arguments specifically about California
repealing civil rights law yeah they the
California assembly and the Senate
repealed this I know most of you
probably know the context by now for
those who don't it's literally just it
says the state shall not discriminate
based on these things so when I hear
them say that was a mistake we need to
undo that I say so what does that mean
for me if you if you never had these
policies perhaps I wouldn't even be here
today maybe that would make you happy of
course it wouldn't make you happy right
okay well then now you're gonna deal
with me right I'm not just gonna go go
quietly into the into the night I'm
gonna stand up and tell you to go eff
off we have equality in this country you
know we have civil rights law and
they're seeking to undo it and
unfortunately there's a lot of them
I can't I when I heard that that
California was was doing that I expected
some sort of like hiccup in the black
lives matter movement to beat like a
screeching halt on the brakes like uh
what did what what are you trying to do
California excuse me what and they're
like no affirmative action and it's like
okay that that was the title of the bill
right what was the language did you read
the bill do you know what you're voting
it they have to vote if you live in
California they know you do some
research please
it's gonna pass it's crazy because
what's gonna happen is in so it's passed
this the assembly in the Senate it's
gonna go for a referendum in November
and it's gonna say support affirmative
action amendment and they are all going
to say yes
and then guess what happens the next day
state institutions across the board will
put up signs saying this race that race
this race yep segregation yep
California will be it's funny for a long
time they were on the forefront they
were the leaders of all this you know
and still leading not in the direction I
want to go though right right you know
that they're bleeding themselves
backwards that's what they're doing now
yeah you know they they jumped into the
air and slipped and now they're falling
back where everyone's like we just
decide we were just walking steadily
forward what do you do in California cuz
I don't I don't understand I well I'm
curious as to like what happens to say
the rock or Jessica Alba or you know
people like people like that yeah Vin
Diesel these are people that are
ethnically ambiguous okay when you have
this idea of white privilege one of the
one of the things I encounter is and
this is this is this is like a story
that my family has their many
experiences when you get into arguments
with something with with different
groups who view you as either white or
not white and they can't tell ya so like
during Occupy Wall Street it was
non-stop all the time because they try
so hard to make everything about race
you know they're like looking at me like
they mostly called me Puerto Rican for
real Porto Rican yep I had one guy come
to me and he said it was like it's great
to see you know a Puerto Rican brother
down here doing it and I'm like I'm
that's not I'm not know what Mexican is
what I get the most okay and it really
depends on like if it you know it was
summer and so I had more of a tan or no
I was tanned and I had I have black
facial hair okay so people just
immediately would come up to me when I
was in Anaheim covering the Trump
rallies okay the you I was like
Telemundo walking from you start
speaking Spanish and I was like oh no no
I'm sorry I'm sorry
and that's what I tend to get when I was
in Egypt that I was Egyptian so perhaps
it's a benefit that in some places
nobody can tell but if they're trying to
quantify and segregate everybody then it
just becomes a problem for me and I'm
like nah man look I may be one person I
may be part of a very small minority and
the problem with that is each
mixed race in the United Sates is a
small minority but each person is a
different mix it's like some people
could be like afro-cuban you could be
Jewish in black you could be Asian and
black
ever so there's no community I've never
had more conversations about race than
these past few months we got a stop we
got stop talking about it why are we
talking about it because the Libertarian
Party they just they won't let it no no
no rat I get it wasn't just be not a
libertarian party you know obviously the
temperature of America right now is they
charged because of racism and it's like
I just it blows me away I you know I
don't I don't look at people I look at
the character of a person if you treat
me nice that's how I want to be nice to
you I want to be nice to everybody I
want everyone B to get along you know so
and give you that people don't people
see one person who's being rude and
equate to their skin color to that
rudeness instead of the the like this is
kind of what this Shelby Steele was
talking about it bringing back
individual accountability and that's
huge we need to be accountable for our
own actions and that's not what people
are doing they're going oh you were you
know I'm gonna stereotype you across the
board and fill my checkbook of what skin
color are you okay cool
this is a type of person all of the skin
color the people that I know that are
like you that's who all of them are it's
like anyone can be awesome
anyone can be thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you